All right, bladesmiths.
Congratulations.
The two of you have made it
through the first two rounds
of our [inaudible]
competition, which means you're
going into the final round.
Now we are giving you four
days at your home forges
to battle it out for the
title of "Forged in Fire"
champion and a
check for $10,000.
We want you to build this--
the Mesopotamian sickle sword.
The sickle sword
originated in Mesopotamia
at the height of the
Bronze Age, around 2500 BC.
These sickle and
curve-shaped swords
often symbolized
royalty and power,
and were primarily
wielded during ceremonies
by kings and authority figures.
Although these swords were
not common on the battlefield,
the belly of the blade allowed
for quick, devastating blows,
and inspired designs
for later weapons,
such as the deadly
Egyptian khopesh.
Good luck.
We will see you in four days.
Go.
My name's Robert Taylor.
I'm from Brentwood, California.
I'm a sergeant with the San
Francisco Sheriff's Department.
I took up bladesmithing
because I liked
watching "Forged in Fire."
It was something I really
wanted to go further in,
become an ABS smith,
maybe a master smith
someday, because I love forging.
So I'm going to go
500 layers of Damascus
on each side with
a 1084 center core.
All right, we're going
for our final forge weld.
As long as I'm
solid with my steel,
1084 will give it a
more stronger center.
The place where I want
to bend will bend down,
and then the tip
will start bending
up automatically as I hit it.
ROBERT (VOICEOVER): I'm
whacking it on the horn
to get it to bend down.
It's easier than
using the hammer.
I like it.
Got the bilt all
ready for the quench.
ROBERT (VOICEOVER): If this
quench doesn't go right,
I'm gonna have to go
ahead and start over.
And that's gonna suck.
Went in pretty hot.
We'll see if we have
any bad forge welds.
We have a hard lake.
I want to keep it light
enough and balanced enough
for somebody to swing it.
Getting there.
Feel really good
about my weapon.
Getting all the fit-up done.
I think this thing's gonna slice
anything they put before it.
My name is Jacob Gates.
I am 20 years old, and I'm
from Royalton, Minnesota.
Martial arts has always been
my first love and first hobby.
And then I got
into bladesmithing.
JACOB (VOICEOVER):
They both kind
of crisscross, because
when you're making a knife,
it's just got to be
real patient with it.
Wax on, wax off.
I'm gonna put a ladder
pattern in this steel.
Kinda can see the ladder
pattern in there already.
The length and
curve of this blade
is gonna be difficult
to work with just
because I want to make sure
everything stays straight
and doesn't have
any warps to it.
Looking good so far.
Because ultimately,
that could send
me home if that's not spot-on.
We're getting ready
to quench here.
I feel pretty good
about my progress.
Everything looks good.
That's a good temperature.
Oh, that is straight.
Everything's looking good.
Now we're gonna
have to temper it.
That's gonna take away a
little of this hardness
and it's gonna' add
toughness, because right
now, it's pretty brittle.
If I just went and
smacked it on my anvil,
it would probably shatter.
I think the hardest
part is gonna
be getting the heat just right.
I don't have an oven
long enough to fit
this sword in so we're gonna
have to do it all with a torch.
It's not going to be as
precise as having an oven.
Don't want to overheat it.
Makes me a little bit
nervous because I don't
know the ultimate outcome.
But hopefully, we
get it just right.
I want to make sure everything
is even on this handle
and everything feels good.
The martial artists,
they're really into flow
and I'm really into feel.
Feels good.
I'm not quite sure what my
strength test is gonna be.
But I think whatever
they throw at it,
it's gonna be able to handle it.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the kill test.
So to find out what kind of
lethal damage they will do,
I'm gonna take your weapons,
deliver some lethal blows
to this ballistics dummy.
Jacob, you're up first.
Ready?
Cut the head off.
Let's do that.
[music playing]
[laughs]
All right, Jacob.
Let's talk about your
sickle sword right here.
Your edge is razor sharp.
Coupled with the fact that
this is a very light weapon,
I can use velocity to really
wield that sharp edge.
It cuts deep into
this ballistics dummy.
And overall, sir, your
weapon, it will kill.
Thank you.
All right, Robert.
Your turn, sir.
You ready?
I'm ready.
Right.
Let's do this.
[music playing]
All right, Robert, let's
talk about your sickle sword.
It's a very light
blade, that much
lighter than the other one.
And the angle that
you have in here
lends itself to use
not only velocity,
but the sharpness of your
edge to cut very deep
into this ballistics dummy.
And overall, sir, it will kill.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the strength test,
the armored warrior chop.
To test the strength and overall
durability of your Mesopotamian
sickle swords, I'm
gonna be chopping
into these armored warriors.
Jacob, you're up first.
You ready for this?
I don't think I get a choice.
You don't have a choice.
[music playing]
What actually happened is your
sword bit into the other sword
by about 3/16 of an inch
and it took out this chip.
And once that chip was gone,
the whole sword blew up.
Your grain looks good.
But unfortunately, it's just
this sword against that sword.
This time, that sword won.
Yep.
All right, Jacob, we
hate to see this happen.
You gave us a beautiful blade.
But unfortunately, it did
suffer catastrophic failure
on the seventh strike.
But you are not out
of the fight yet,
because Robert, in order
to become the champion,
you will have to survive every
single one of those seven
strikes on the armored warrior.
Are you ready?
Let's roll the dice.
All right, Ben.
[music playing]
Well, Robert, the big
thing is it's one sword.
Nice job.
Thank you.
Well, Robert, you made
it through all the testing.
Jacob, it's a beautiful
piece of work.
Unfortunately, due to
your catastrophic failure,
we cannot continue testing.
And for that reason, I'm gonna
have to ask you to please
step off the forge floor.
Thank you, gentlemen.
It was an honor.
Thank you very much.
Very nice job.
Thank you.
You know, it totally sucks.
JACOB (VOICEOVER): But I
really am proud of the blade
I made either way.
You know, they said pretty
much nothing but good things
about it, up until it broke.
And, well, I'd totally
come back for this
and maybe get a shot at
making it all the way through.
Robert, we never like to
see competitors' blades break.
But yours did not, and
that makes you the newest
"Forged in Fire" champion.
You just got yourself
a check for $10,000.
Congratulations.
Thanks.
[applause]
Feel pretty good?
Crazy, dude.
Crazy.
[laughter]
ROBERT (VOICEOVER): Winning
this championship, I think,
has really pushed
me to my limits.
And then that makes me want
to push them even more.
Now that I'm a
champion, I'm gonna
go ahead and get my
ABS Smith membership
and just really
refine my skills.